décembre au 1er janvier des voitures ont
brûlé dans de très nombreuses villes en
france
cela devient une tradition révoltante
qu'il est urgent d'endiguer à strasbourg
la situation a été particulièrement
tendue
le maire estime à 220 le nombre de
voitures brûlées et les policiers ont
été bien sûr pris pour cible je viens de
m'entretenir avec les responsables du
sdiss du bas-rhin ce qu'ont vécu les
pompiers ce soir la donne une idée du
niveau de violence dans certains
quartiers et du niveau de rennes chez
certains de nos concitoyens à 2 heures
du matin les sapeurs-pompiers ont fait
face à une violence jusqu'ici inédite
dans la cité nucléaire l'une des plus
importantes de strasbourg les jeunes
assaillants luron les termes en
littéralement tendu un guet-apens aux
moyens de barrage constitué de poubelles
en flammes les pompiers raconte qu ils
ont été encerclés
le but étant de les lyncher un sapeur
pompier a reçu un projectile à la tête
qu'il aurait à coup sûr tuer s'il
n'avait pas eu de casques sans la
dextérité du chauffeur du camion
l'équipage à l'intérieur aurait été
agressée est assailli il ne s'agissait
plus seulement de casser du matériel
mais de s'en prendre physiquement aux
équipages
les sapeurs-pompiers ont témoigné de la
préméditation de ces agressions qui ont
d'ailleurs été filmée par ces voyous
monsieur miss monsieur le ministre je
vous mets en garde
les propose indignés ne suffiront plus
les condamnations journal de 20h non
plus il faut ouvrir les yeux et nous
dire ce que vous comptez faire pour que
ces nuits de violence ne se reproduise
plus comment comptez vous protéger nos
pompiers
comment comptez vous reconquérir ces
enclaves qui échappe à la république et
qui sont minés par le communautarisme
par ailleurs pouvez vous nous dire
combien de voitures en france ont brûlé
dans la nuit de la saint sylvestre
les français ont le droit de savoir et
les élus ont besoin de connaître la
réalité chiffrée la presse ce matin
parlait de 1457 voitures brûlées + 13 %
par rapport à l'an passé
pouvez vous nous le confirmer j'attends
dans votre réponse en chiffres précis au
conclure ce n'est pas en cachant le
problème que vous règlerez le que vous
le réguler